bonjour à tous alors quoi de beau ce
weekend dans les yelines c'est Halloween
ça fait peur là on va avoir très peur on
est dans un parking pour l'occasion ça
fait super peur j'espère qu'il va faire
beau en ce joli mois d'octobre qui se
termine parce que c'est Halloween il y a
des citrouilles
partout on va aussi aller chercher des
bonbons on va faire une chasse au
bonbons on va se déguiser parce que
c'est Halloween faut se déguiser attends
il y a un truc
ouais tu l'as vu peur oua ça fait peur
ça fait peur hein oh là oh là attends
mais on est d'accord qu'il y a un truc
là tu l'as vu
non je crois que je deviens fou que j'ai
peur parce que c'est
Halloween là là tu l'as
[Musique]
vu
monsieur qui que vous soyez vous êtes un
méchant tu
vois monsieur je crois qu'il est
armé aucun mal nous
[Musique]
super alors quoi de bon à cause du
manque d'organisation du présentateur et
du fait de son incompétence la séquence
qui suit n'a aucun rapport avec la
précédente nous nous excusons pour ce
désagrément l'équipe alors quoi de beau
put mais c'est lourd hein on va voir les
professionnels pe on peut vous regarder
vous avez l'air de savoir faire euh
ouais alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait on lui
fait une bouche comme ça triangle avec
des T triangle donc ça c'est un triangle
ah ouais elle est bien ta bouche elle
est bien moi je pense qu'elle est bien
parce que j'ai mis les dents jaune ah
oui ok tu as choisi la couleur alors oui
et si elle faisait un crit il ferait
croire comme crit à citrouille
voir plus
fort encore plus
fort faut que je la vide est-ce que tu
pourrais nous aider pour la découpe
sinon je prends un couteau et je me
coupe le doigt
mais et mettre làdedans et ça c'est le
compost donc on peut pas mettre tout ce
qui
est voilà
exactement transition nettoy le allez là
je vais m'inspirer des professionnels
alors comment je fais là pour faire
faire peur moi il faut faire une bouche
avec des petites dents he Hotman ouais
et pour moi elle fait pas peur toi tu
fais pas peur là elle fait peur là
regarde pe pe peu peur voilà elle fait
un tout petit peu peur quand même non
oui quand même bib peu là là elle fait
peur là fait peur toujours pas peur mais
pourtant elle dit qu'elle fait peur
qu'est-ce que tu en penses toiman elle
fait pas peur si tuoses même pas la
regarder ou regarde regarde tuoses même
pas la regarder tellement fait peur non
si là tu regardes oui là elle fait peur
oume qume alors tuas pas peur sourcil
français Noras pe la notre fait plus
peur ah fais voir fais voir fais voir
ouais ah ouais celleel elle fait
vraiment peur hein elle fait quel bruit
si elle pouvit faire du
bruit ça ça peur moi j'ai pas eu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
peur
on a gagné c'est pas grave tu peux
[Rires]
pantalon elle fait quel bruit la mienne
fait ah ouis j'ai pas eu peur là moi il
a pas eu
peur est-ce que ma citrouille fait peur
attention attends je vous la montre mais
pas tout de suite fait peur je vous
préviens d'abord
okar même pas à la
regarder pe est-ce que vous êtes prê
avoir
peur pe
voir ta citrouille toi et vous vous
trouvez vraiment que ça citrouille fait
peur bon reprenons là où nous en
étions ok on a échappé belle on a qu'à
se maquiller pour se camoufler parmi
tous les gens
d'Halloween fait peur un truc qui fait
très très peur comme ça on fera plus
peur à la personne qui nous faisit peur
bonjour monsieur salut chef tu as trouvé
où ton masque je le cherche encore ou
super bien fait il y a pas de maquillage
rien là
réaliste plus ça fait peur tu fais un
bruit quand tu fais
[Musique]
peur votre masque
mon
masque pas mal il est réaliste on a
envie d'un truc qui fait peur comme vous
comme moi écoutez voilà c'est naturel
c'est ça qui est bien bien joué je vais
chercher pareil moi c'est incroyable on
a vu quelqu'un avec le même masque juste
là il avait le même masque vous ça c'est
fou
ça il fait fur on peut le trouver où
tonque non je dis pas je dis pas ah ou
non c'est un secret ça je dis pasne
chance à tout à l'heure à tout à
l'heure merci Estelle a pas de souci
c'est trop bien merci là on va faire
peur là là tu V faire peur on va faire
très très peur vous avez des bonbons là
ouais un
peu je peux
ouaiservez-vous mercichet des bonbons
des bonbons ouais on B on arrive les
bonbons bonbons c'est où les bonbons
c'est pas les bonbons ah c'est là les
bonbons bonjour regarde c'est là vous
êes pas Monsieur Merci vous aussi trop
bien votre costume je par en courant
nonz chef vous avez des beau masques
tous les deux ils sont beau V
déguisement il a un
dinosaure allez
là c'est quoi ton costume PL m pl oui je
connais pas superér oui ok tuas beaucoup
de bonbons là oui
[Musique]
allez et tu fais les griffes un peu ah
ouais moi j'avais compris que c'est la
plaque dur mais c'est pas plaque dentire
superhéros des dentistes non non c'est
pas lui ok salut salut blat mter tu
penses qu'ils ont désactivé la
sonnerie
bonsoir salut on vient donner des
bonbons aux gens donner des bonbons pour
pouvoir les rendre aux enfants d'accord
tuas pas beaucoup de gens qui passent
ici un petit peu si si a une petite
dizaine là là il y il y a Black Panther
qui passe là d'accord il va arriver je
pense je vais faire une
offrande bonsoir madame merci he merci
Madame merci Madame bonjour sympa votre
costume on va pas se laisser avoir c'est
la concurrence là h c'est notre maison
ça et c'était nos bonbons là vous voulez
des bonbons on en a ouais trop
oh
ohilleur celui-là oh ah lui c'est un
beau regarde et tu sais quoi le clown il
donne des bonbons
ouais ah Timothé oui cri lui dessus
vas-y bravo bravo
Timothé merci il fait peur
[Musique]
Timothé fait pas peur fait pas peur
vas-y fais le bruit toi celle-là C
ah j'ai pas peur non et toi faisle pour
voir ah ouais ça faitjà pe dans la
douleur vasy avec comme ça
c'est
bon